anyways by the way did you guys see uh
the the how uh biden was the life of the
party just a couple days ago put it up
there how he was like everybody people
he had a line of people trying to talk
to him let's let's take a look at this
if you haven't seen this make that okay
there you go
do you have audio or no
okay if you want to put the audio put
the audio because it's c-span we're
paying for this
nobody wants to talk to him
and watch the way obama ignores him when
he puts the hand watch
this he knows the president of the
united states is touching him right now
he knows it and just look at that he's
leaning on him
okay so so
let's let's process this let's process
this from three different angles and i
want to get your perspective on this one
how do our enemies process that so putin
how do
maybe you know uh and iran a china xi
not necessarily enemy but they're not
our allies right how does
what is barack obama's motive here is he
coming in and saying hello vice
president joe biden and he says this was
part of the skit we talked about it
undermining him
and number three
biden himself
is he sitting there thinking in his own
mind with nobody telling him this not
his advisors not his peers nobody's
saying
i think i may be replaced here right
after november midterms what give me
give it to me perspective from those
three lenses i think it frightens our
enemies because they look at this video
and they say oh my gosh
he has superpowers he can be invisible
and walk around a room this is a
dangerous guy tom this is why you could
only be a comedian around big
universities that have technical minds
but but go ahead what are you doing no i
was a pg orc fan
well first first i will address that but
did you guys see the video from about a
year or two ago we showed it on my show
i think yesterday of obama saying that
what his dream would be to have a third
term but he would just need a dummy out
there and he would just be able to talk
to them in their ear basically he would
just need a body he said that two years
yeah i'll send you the video later he
said it about a year ago that that would
be his true dream he would love a third
term where he was the puppet master
by the way i'm totally cool with that
if obama is actually running the show
and not biden oh i'm just saying i'm
cool with that oh we do have a little
work to do with you still okay okay
we'll get you you'd rather bide and be
at the helm is that where you're no but
no but biden obviously isn't in charge
it's not that's a question so in essence
yes i do think which gets to your
question oh this is it this is it yeah
um is it suspect i think it's it's or
what is it
yeah
i think there's another factor of this
but dave rubin well first i would say
that biden obviously is not in charge i
think what sort of happened in that
moment is that everyone realizes how bad
all of this is we all know inflation
supply chain
ukraine afghanistan okay all the stuff
right we all know how bad it is we know
the polls are terrible all of that
everyone also knows that kamala was
polling at zero literally zero in her
own party when she dropped out and then
they chose her quite simply because of
the color of her skin we we see these
are she was a black female and her
genitals yes so
they know that this thing is so damaged
right now
that the other part is that joe biden
has dementia or or something like
dementia he then that is very sad i
don't mean it to be glib or anything
else
i don't think he's going to even make it
between that and now it's coming out
with the hunter biden laptop so i think
the system is now figuring out a way to
push him out the fact that jenn saki
just announced this week that she's
leaving to of course go to msnbc so
she's the chief liar paid liar in
america and now she's going to do it
just on a tv channel i think the system
is shifting and it's realizing man biden
dementia all the problems and and what
obama did right there was sort of just
assert him he just pushed himself back
in and obviously he's not going to get a
third term in a traditional sense but
they'll let kamala take over
and she will probably just have to kiss
the obama ring and do exactly what
you're asking for which i think will
lead to an awful lot of bad policies
that are just a continuation of what's
going on yeah okay so put a timeline on
it is are they are they are the looming
midterms the last straw or is that their
is that their flash point or their well
look the thing is their convenient
milestone you always have to remember
the machine does crazy things so
obviously right now everyone thinks it's
going to be the crazy red wave right
everyone that's what every pole is
saying everyone's predicting it you know
what kovid magically comes back in
october and suddenly it's male in
balloting and harvest ballot harvesting
and all the blue states and then
suddenly it's not such a wave and then
they can
you know who knows but that it's a game
it's it's a giant game of thrones chess
game that is that is many layered beyond
just what the republicans voted 51-48 on
this thing
so that that's basically who did they
replace them with though i mean so so
now you then it goes to the bench okay
so the bench becomes what pete buddhich
that's the bench he's gay
good enough who's defense good enough i
think he's really smart guy i don't i
mean he's only run a small town in
south bend indiana why is he the
transportation secretary i don't know
nobody knows the same
are you trying to say that you're going
to be the next transportation secretary
is that what you're saying but i'm as
qualified as pete
i can tell you that his confirmation
hearing was something of a joke yeah uh
well were there vehicles in your town
yeah yes there were is there a bus
service yes
uh i'm i'm done with my list senator
yeah no that's it that's nothing there
is nothing to how do you process this
because you probably well let me just
say this
i think very number one you're not far
off dave i don't think i'm not willing
to say that biden has dementia but
clearly he ain't exactly all that are
you is anyone at this table confident
that the president of the united states
is cognitively able to be the president
right now and truly making all of the
decisions
i don't think he's making all decisions
i think it's speculation what he has i
don't know
he did handle you know his speech about
ukraine and like i thought you even said
that he did a decent job with that
um it's the best i've seen him do okay
and that was a month ago so every now
and again he can snort adderall and
basically read a teleprompter i mean
that's basically it you know i like that
um
but
let's
let's play a game if pence was the
president
right and he's doing you know mike pence
type things and trump rolls into the
white house you don't think everyone's
just going to be grabbing on trump and
pence will be kind of walking around
like a pencil neck i think it's a very
similar like it's a yearning for
something better is really what it is
and obama shows up and everyone's like
holy [ __ ] this is the guy
much like i think that's exactly what
would happen in a if if trump left and
pence was the president but what do you
guys think about the respect level that
moment when he put his hand on his
shoulder you it's not like people can
just walk up to barack obama and touch
him yeah and and biden's right behind
him clearly talking to him
it's not he doesn't have no sensors
right no sensory abilities no it was
yours
sorry obama knew what was happening he
went out of his way to ignore him and
continue to like does that seem crazy to
you that he's making some sort of move
no it did it was clear yeah so think
about it this way say you say you uh we
run sales officers so say i go into one
of my sales guys's office and the guy
who runs that office he's a sales leader
say i spend one hour just
undermining him and talking about how
special i am
what the hell am i doing am i building
leaders so to me that didn't come across
as biden being a trump uh what's his
name obama being a king maker that came
across as obama being a king not a king
maker right he has an opportunity to be
known as a king maker now that's a next
level type of stuff because now you're
in the league of you know reagan who he
helped someone become a king maker bush
senior was made
through
reagan being the king maker lincoln
ulysses s grant two term president king
maker and that didn't come across as a
king man you came in to steal the show
and it wasn't about you obama it's about
the current president and it didn't
happen so that was a that was a hit a
mis opportunity on his end and in
regards to how people view it it doesn't
look strong at all uh obama looked like
he
was semi condescending a little bit like
yeah you know
i got that feeling from him that was a
little bit kind of let me ask you yeah
because you're bringing up your sales
leaders and your offices you travel
it'd be the equivalent it's like i'm
almost going to make an analogy here
you're obama and you roll up to one of
your offices in houston
and they're usually following their
sales leader yeah you know call him jim
but you roll up
jim's the man 364 days a year but pat
shows up
and everyone in the office starts paying
attention to pat i've seen what happens
when you roll up to the office
there's signs welcome pat
there's a little bit of that in that
right yeah but your job is to build that
person up yeah your job is to build that
person i totally get it like your job is
to like for example the dylan's coach
right dylan's coach ricky is teaching
him how to do baseball every time he's
teaching him i go stand right there okay
and i'll tell him i say hey
so you challenge him you pushed him a
little bit but you seem uncomfortable
tell me why well listen patrick you know
sometimes parents i said i'm not that
parent keep pushing him i want to
empower you he says you have no idea how
important this is you know every single
time after a game he's talking to dylan
because he's got an insurance policy
from me because i empowered him now let
me give you the flip side of the coin is
sometimes
that leader is doing a shitty job which
is here and sometimes if the leader's
doing a shitty job you come up you're
like dude
i don't want my reputation to be tied to
him because
obama may have three other moves that no
one knows about on how to replace them
in december and november but no one
knows about that and that narrative is
going to change like this first of all
let me simplify something for you guys
andrew cuomo went from winning a flippin
emmy and writing a book getting a 5
million advance and he was ahead of
trump every day would listen to him in
his press conference he would do six
months later boom they dropped him and
he's disappeared when's the last time he
signed cuomo what have you heard about
he was a hero he was gonna beat trump he
would have been so much more
presidential this guy would have been so
much more presidential do not be
surprised if they drop biden like a bad
habit in literally seconds it's boom
it's happening now he disappears and
he's gone do you agree with him dave a
hundred percent yeah a hundred percent
people need to understand what politics
is and you just explained what it is it
is it is game of thrones it is game of
thrones they have used by biden remember
obama did not even support biden
throughout most of the primary remember
that everyone kept saying well why isn't
he supporting his guy because he knew it
was seriously damaged also don't forget
nobody really wanted biden remember at
that moment when
mike bloomberg ran his fake presidential
candidacy for a month and they threw him
on stage twice and it was awful
embarrassingly
embarrassing made 100 million dollars
for that 100 million dollars for and he
obviously didn't want to be president
but they all felt man biden is bad but
they needed to figure out who was it
going to be and was it going to be gay
pete or elizabeth warren who's a
socialist or crazy bernie so they all
coalesced around the guy that was sort
of loosely holding together the old
thing that we kind of remember bloomberg
i remember that vividly
yeah wait did you say you campaigned for
him i went to one of his events jesus in
miami francis suarez was there i want to
say so
just so you know when we're done with
him yeah you guys got to play basketball
no we'll play basketball but i mean when
we've completely like turned him
i'm taking you what's
what's your favorite restaurant what is
like what is the greatest place i could
take you just as the fire as the floor
anywhere anywhere i think you literally
would be right
here it'd be casa d'angelo okay i've
never been there no but we need to go to
carbona in miami
i haven't been yet everyone's freaking
out you've moved to miami you've got to
go to carbon every every day somebody
said are you saying you're taking us to
carpenters
when you're when we are done with you
signed sealed delivered registered
republican but that would be no fun dave
we wouldn't have any confidence wait a
minute wait a minute
we can one-up it why don't we take him
to mar-a-lago
we can if you enjoyed this short clip
click over here to watch another short
clip and if you want to watch the entire
episode the entire podcast click here
[Music]